Hello everyone, my name is Abhishek. I'm
the solo founder and developer of
Arachis, an open-source code execution
and computer use sandboxing service for
AI agents. Today we'll chat about why
sandboxing is the next big unlock in
intelligence and what goes into building
an AI sandbox
like a little bit about my background. I
went to school at Carnegie Melon where I
studied distributed systems and
operating systems. At Microsoft, I
worked on Windows Subsystem for Linux
and a smart watch OS from scratch. At
Google, I worked on cutting edge systems
using containers and inventing something
called microVMs, which we'll discuss in
plenty detail today. The last couple of
years, I was at Replet working on infra
and rack based code chat before I
founded Ara right at the intersection of
my background in operating systems,
sandboxes, and AI agents.
So why do we need AI
sandboxes? For one, the latest models
like 03 all leverage tool calling such
as search or code exec during inference
to give smarter replies to user queries.
These tool calls require AI sandboxes
for execution. For reinforcement
learning as well during the training
phase, you need sandboxes to run reward
functions at
scale. Agents can also go a long way
with the full Linux sandbox at their
disposal. For example, during code
generation, they can debug entire apps
by using Linux commands like ps lsoft to
see if the code is running and debugging
it. They can backtrack, replan, and work
towards the goal again with a sandbox at
their disposal. Security is paramount.
Agent code is no different than you
using any code from GitHub or Stack
Overflow and running it on your host or
production server. This code could be
buggy or malicious and can get root and
can access your data or your client's
data. So we need some amount of locking
down uh in this
sandbox. Let's see a sandbox around us.
I know we've seen uh canvas by OpenAI
claw artifacts. This is Manas AI. Uh it
uses a sandbox very heavily. Uh you can
see that I've asked it to create a chat
GPT clone and it it's running all sorts
of commands inside the Linux sandbox. Uh
it will also try to run the app, see if
it didn't work and then try to fix it
itself. You don't need a big prompt or a
lot of like uh alignment and frameworks
to make a coding agent when it has a
Linux sandbox at its disposal just
because it has all of this uh like Linux
knowledge uh in its pre-training data.
So it could go a long way uh for code
generation tasks inside the sandbox.
With that background, introducing
Arachus. Arachus provides a secure,
fully customizable and self-hosted
solution to spawn and manage AI
sandboxes for code execution and
computer use. It has out ofthe-box
support for backtracking via snapshot
and restore. And what that means is
agents can backtrack and don't have to
start from scratch if they fail during
multi-step workflows. Best of all, it is
completely open source and you can dive
into the code and we will do that today
to see how to make an AI sandbox like
Arachus from
scratch. Now let's go over the features
of Arachus. U let's start with microVM
based secure code
execution. As discussed, security is
paramount for AI sandboxes. Arachus uses
microVMs as a runtime and we'll go into
more detail there. But like I mentioned
code generated by AI AI agents would
increase exponentially uh as people are
using windsurf cursor and more and more
coding agents. We don't want these
malicious or potentially buggy code to
get root and we want to protect your
data, your systems, your client's data.
Um second is speed. Speed is paramount
for AI sandboxes. You want these things
at scale to be able to call tools,
generate code fast. Currently, Iraqis
boots in less than 7 seconds, which is
way way better than 40 seconds for a
traditional old VM on Mac OS. We have a
PR out right now to get that time below
a second. Um, also snapshots are super
fast, singledigit seconds and just
getting uh lower and lower with
work. Uh, Arais handles all also port
forwarding for you. So, code exec
browser use, you can access them easily
uh via just a public URL and a port. You
don't have to muck with IP tables,
firewalls. Arachis takes care of all of
that. Easy computer use agent sort of
workflows. Chrome is pre-installed and
there's a VNC server that's hooked up
pre-installed and so you can access the
guey of your browser very easily. Uh you
can see uh Chrome instance opened in an
Ara sandbox here.
Um backtracking is super in important as
well. Like I mentioned, Ara supports
snapshot and restore. So agents can
checkpoint progress by snapshotting the
sandbox. If they fail in their
multi-step flows, they can restore an
old snapshot. Uh this way we can get
more reliable, higher order complex task
execution via
agents. Arachus is a dead simple and
ubiquitous API. Uh it has a Python API,
a Golang client and MCP server. It has
an open API compatible YAML file. So you
can generate any client in any language
that you want.
Lastly, it's configurable with Docker
tooling. So, you can use your existing
Docker commands and there's a Docker
file to customize what binaries and
packages are installed in the sandbox.
So, Arachus gives you complete control
and freedom on what you want to run
inside your
sandbox. So, this is the highle
architecture of Arachus. Uh you can see
it has a REST server that spawns and
manages microVM sandboxes. Each of the
sandboxes runs a VNC server and a code
server. We do the port forwarding to
expose a VNC server and you can access
the guey and chrome via VNC client. We
give a rackis CLI Golang based CLI
called a rack client. There's a Python
SDK. There's also an MCP server that's
not shown here. Uh so there's a lot
going on here but in the next half of
the presentation we'll work towards what
all go inside each of these uh
components and see how an AI sandbox uh
is made. Um, Arachus is tied to Linux
just because the microVM tech that we
used uh is tied to uh dev KVM which is
the Linux virtualization uh device. So
it's tied to the Linux virtualization
stack. Let's move to the API of Arachus.
And uh you can see we have a very simple
rest based API. uh there's a key VMs uh
uh resource that you use to like uh like
start, stop, delete a VM. Inside that
you can you also have a snapshots
resource. So you can like snapshot a VM
very easily by this snapshots API and
within a VM you get command execution
with the command resource and you can
upload and download files from within
the sandbox using the files API. And
finally, there's a health check endpoint
as well. If you want uh to have a
distributed version and you want to see
the health of your Arachus REST server,
uh this is what the API
exposes. Okay, we discussed about the
API that Arachus exposes and now we have
an updated architecture. We can see that
we have a rest server running on a Linux
host or a Linux server uh exposing a
REST API uh via the Python SDK or the
Golang uh CLI. We also have an M MCP
server and an open API uh based YAML
file that you can use to generate
clients in any languages. Um and we'll
keep updating this architecture as we go
inside the architecture of the sandbox.
Uh so let's move forward.
Arachus uses something called microVMs
to give secure sandboxes to uh models
and AI agents. Uh but what are microVMs
and why do they or how do they provide a
secure environment? For that, let's take
a quick tour of Linux sandboxing and
I'll build from scratch uh your
knowledge about Linux sandboxing and
what are different options are and why
we chose
microVMs. Let's start with the Linux
execution model. So this diagram kind of
goes over the basic Linux execution
model. Uh a thread is the smallest unit
of execution on Linux. Each thread has a
task truck in the kernel that's in the
scheduleuler run Q. And what that means
is there's a link list or a data
structure uh connecting these like task
trucks and these are used to represent
uh each thread or the unit of execution.
A process is a logical construct made up
of multiple threads. Um threads in a
process have different tids but the same
pit. They share page table and other
resources. Uh and so they're logically
bound and connected by shared resources.
Uh kernel provides privileged access to
hardware. Um if this wasn't the case
then any buggy or malicious uh uh like
code running in a thread can just crash
an entire device or or do malicious
things. Um and special instructions are
needed to switch to kernel mode uh or
supervisor mode. Um and we need to
invoke a system call for privileged
access. Uh and so you can see in the
diagram when we do like int o o x80
that's us trying to get to privileged
mode and uh get access to hardware or do
like privileged operations on our
OS. Okay, we've discussed the basic
Linux threadbased execution model. Now
let's discuss about containers. Uh why
do we have them and what they are? So
first uh let me give you a programmer's
perspective of uh what problem
containers solve. Uh and so in this
diagram you can see a container and the
concept of name spaces. But yeah let's
dive deeper. Um so first why like let's
say my app needs Python 3.8 uh a version
of a library fu with 1.2 and my server
has Python 3.9 3.6 3.12 but doesn't have
3.8 and it doesn't even have the library
fu. So how do I run my app on like an
arbitrary server without these things
right? And so containers from a
programmer's perspective are a way to
package an app's dependencies along with
the core business logic. Um uh as a
corollery they let you run arbitrary
user code on your machine which as we've
discussed is one of the core features
required by an AI sandbox. Um getting
more technical on a Linux a container is
a collection of namespaces of different
resources. So process mount and net for
our example of key resources that you
can abstract in namespaces. What that
means is like if you have a process name
space uh for instance in a container um
it sees certain processes as pit 1, pit
2 and pit 3 within its name space but
outside these are like arbitrary
processes uh running in the user space
in the root name space. So container has
a very like uh abstracted or bound view
of its own resources. Uh and the host
can peak inside a child container
namespace but a container cannot like
look upwards and see in its host name
space. So this is one way of like
um telling processes or like contents
running in the container uh that like
you have your own uh controllable like
resources u uh and it's like a little
bit of a false boundary so to speak. Uh
so like I said yeah outside the
container you can see everything inside
your inside your child's namespace but
it doesn't work the opposite way. uh we
also use something called croups uh in
tandem with namespaces. So containers
are collections of namespaces and croups
like uh can control how many resource a
resource and container can uh access. So
what percentage of memory, what
percentage of CPU do you want to give uh
to a specific container running on your
machine. Let's talk about the security
story of containers.
Um and so here you can see a container
uh consisting of a paid name space
running on top
of a a kernel uh on a server. Uh and so
you can see that after all containers
run as native processes on top of the
kernel. U there's a logical binding of
resources but at the end these are just
like processes running on top of the
kernel. So you can imagine now that if
you have a kernel vulnerability um uh
any malicious or buggy process can
attack the kernel and gain root and then
once it became becomes root it can do
basically anything it wants. It can dump
me. It can read your data. It can like
pretend to be like uh someone it's not.
So all sorts of attack vectors are on
the
cards. Okay. So we now know what
containers are and like what's what one
of the security flaws that containers
have. Um so what are what are the
alternatives like uh how can we let's
say like sandbox or jail container uh to
kind of mitigate these things. So let's
look into
that right and so like I said like if
there's a kernel vulnerability a
container can attack it and get root but
let's see how we can reduce the attack
surface by uh using some techniques that
we have. So one is like the fundamental
principle is to jail the containers by
restricting like the Linux capabilities
and like the sys calls they can call and
so in effect reducing the attack surface
that's available to it and so the way
this works is right like Linux has a
concept of caps or capabilities and that
kind of govern what sys calls or
privileged operations a process can do
and so you only give capabilities that
are required by your container to do its
work. you don't give it like a catch
all. Um and these indirectly control
what system calls and what code paths
they can take within the system call.
Another thing is sec which like uh
filters the arguments you can give to a
system call or just block system calls
all together. So sec filters is another
option. Um and so you can these are like
gnarly or hard to use APIs with a lot of
granular error checking. So there's a
library called mini jail that we used to
use at Chrome OS that I highly recommend
to check out that helps in like jailing
and sandboxing of uh containers and
processes. Okay, sandboxing can only go
so far and jails also have their limits.
This can still bypass them. Uh let's say
you need a heavier hammer, right? Uh
what options do we have? So let's
discuss going from containers to
virtualization on
Linux. So let's discuss a highle view of
virtualization. Um, virtualization
provides another primitive to run
untrusted or arbitrary code on your
machines. Um, each VM has its own guest
user space and guest kernel. And so
unlike the container model where the
processes run directly on top of the
host kernel, uh, this in this way the
processes have their own isolated kernel
and user space. And um, there's a very
little there's a smaller attack surface
to get to the host kernel compared to a
container. And so the question is in
this diagram like you need to access
like hardware and other like resources.
So how do VMs then access the host
resources in this virtualization model
on
Linux. Okay. Now let's dive deeper into
Linux
virtualization. Yeah, as you can see
that uh this is a more fleshed out
diagram of Linux virtualization. Let me
go over the main parts here. So on the
right hand side there's some client that
wants to spawn a virtual machine. Um and
the main actor here is this process
called the VMM. The virtual machine
monitor and you might have heard of QMU
CrossVM or firecracker. The main process
here is the VMM. The VMM sits on top of
devk which is like a device in the Linux
kernel that exposes uh the processor's
virtualization stack uh and provides a
nice API for the VMM process uh to talk
to in order to start a VM uh and uh give
it access to privileged resources. Uh so
let's discuss how this works. Um the VMM
talks to the KVM device to spawn VMs and
it also manages emulated devices inside.
So you can see there's a block device
and there's a net device. Some VMMs
spawn these in other uh sandbox
processes and some VMMs have them in the
same process. Um to the client process
it looks like the VMM thread is blocked
but really inside that thread we are
running all the guest code on the
hardware. So in a separate
virtualization context on your processor
this hardware code is running whenever
the virtual machine needs to access disk
or net or any other like privilege
resource on the host. It returns back to
the host. So the VMM process gets a VM
exit uh and then it figures out why the
exit happened like which device caused
the exit block net or something else. It
then talks to the host kernel to do talk
to the block disk device or the net
device gets the response and sends it
back to the guest with a VM resume. So
the whole the whole idea is that VM
exits and resumes are very very like
performance uh uh uh affecting and so
you want to minimize this and want to
keep the uh guest code running in the
guest context as much as possible. So if
you're like CPU bound inside the guest,
you're technically paying no penalty in
a uh hardware virtualization model
because you're running directly on the
processor. But if you need a lot of like
disk and net and other device access uh
then there are other ways to you to
think about performance because you
might be exiting too often. Uh and there
are other things you can do. You can
cache more state and the guest memory
and things but but yeah containers run
directly on top of your host OS. So
performance isn't uh a big factor
because they're like native processes
but the trade-off is of security. Here
you get better security but in some
loads the trade-off might be in
performance. Okay, we've now discussed
Linux virtualization and how it works.
So what are microVMs and how do they
differ from traditional VMs? Um so let's
take a
look. Okay. And so as you can see that
um microVMs are slightly different from
traditional VMs. So first of all um this
term came from the crossvm project at
chrome OS. CrossVM was the first rust
based virtual machine monitor monitor
and the reason we rewrote uh QMU like
VMMs into Rust is they provide uh a
memory safe implementation of
virtualization. And so one aspect is
that u technically untrusted code
running in a guest can attack your host
by attacking the devices written in C
which have like memory safety related
bugs. Um so writing rust gives you some
degree of uh sanity there separately.
Another feature of these VMMs is they
jail their emulated devices separately.
So um you can jail the block device to
only have block related system calls. So
if you compromise block you won't access
network related things and vice versa
you jail the net device to just have
network related system calls. So yeah
one way microvms are different is
they're written in rust and they have
this like more jailing uh based
architecture for their emulated devices.
And so one aspect is security. The other
aspect is why are they called micro VMs?
Where does a micro come from? And like
they're known to boot really fast. So
why and how do they boot fast? and also
like take less memory.
So old VMMs like QMU support a lot of
architectures and have many many
emulated devices supported. Um uh
microVMs like cross VM, firecracker,
cloud hypervisor don't do that. They
only support like one or two
architectures Intel and ARM and have
support for the major devices and not
like any like uh obscure device as well.
What this means is that there's less
code, less code paths at boot. Uh, and
so they just boot up blazing fast and at
runtime like take less memory. Uh, and
so the microVM, the micro is actually a
reflection of the VMM process either
crossVM or firecracker versus what's
running inside the guest. And so you can
think of microVM as this new security
first way of running virtual machines
that are like lighter weight, boost,
boot fast, and consume less memory.
Okay, hopefully that background was
useful on the different ways of
sandboxing untrusted code on Linux. Oh,
so with that, Arachis chooses a microVM
runtime as the final execution
environment for these AI sandboxes. Uh
and so security is one of the key design
choices of rack is because it's written
it's written with coding agents in mind
and coding agents might use um might
have multi-tenant or like different
clients uh running on the same server uh
with LLM generated code accessing
different clients data. So we don't want
uh one piece of untrusted code getting
root on your server and accessing some
other uh client's data. And so
multi-tenant code execution is untrusted
code execution is a very very uh key use
case and design factor behind choosing
microVMs. They also provide fast boot
times as we discussed. Uh snapshotting
is super important for Arachus and
microVMs provide a way to fast snapshot
by just dumping the entire guest memory.
This isn't as easy to do with containers
and uh even with G visor that we'll
discuss. uh and with microVMs you can
just allocate uh some virtual memory and
then just dump it when you want to
snapshot and restore it when you want to
restore the VM. uh and so I wanted to
discuss like different VMMs that we have
the option of choosing. So like I said
crossVM started the whole microVM
revolution and with that came a bunch of
other rust based VMM. So firecracker and
cloud hypervisor are two VMMs folk from
crossvm. If you go over the codebase,
you'll see many remnants of crossVM in
both. Um, firecracker is the
underpinninging behind AWS Lambda. It's
used for like serverless serverless
loads. Um, and uh, it has a more fleshed
out like REST API, I would say, and it
also has a better jailing architecture.
Cloud hypervisor is a more general
purpose enterprise VMM. uh when I chose
it, it had hot plugging of devices,
which means you could add and remove RAM
uh very easily as a PCI device when
you're running a sandbox. It had GPU
support and it had snapshot support at
the time. Uh and from a software project
point of view, it it isn't controlled by
one specific company. There are
different companies there. So, it made a
lot of sense to use cloud hypervisor as
the microVM VMM for Arais. Uh another
option we didn't discuss separate from
microVMs is G Visor which I would say is
closer to a container uh in performance
and like uh but slightly better in
security still you can attack the host
kernel with untrusted code running in G
Visor but based on your needs and
security guarantees um it's a good in
between option you do get GPU access
more easily in G Visor and containers
versus like microVMs so if that's a
factor then you and choose one of those
and decide what your security guarantees
are. Okay, so now we've discussed why we
chose cloud hypervisor and microvms as
the runtime for AI sandboxes and
rackets. Uh let's move
forward. Okay, so now we can see that uh
there's the uh updated architecture from
the one we started off before. So
earlier we had just an API. Now we can
see that uh the rest server is managing
these uh microVM based sandboxes. The
dotted process is actually the cloud
hypervisor VMM process. Um it runs uh
the guest code in a thread in a virtual
context and it's talking to devk um to
uh run these like microb virtual
machines. Um okay so let's move forward.
Okay. Now let's discuss the storage or
the file system within each sandbox.
After all, it might need to create
files, read from them, and write to
them. Um, and so one attack vector we
haven't considered is like untrusted,
malicious or buggy code that can
actually delete files inside your
sandbox and it could delete very
important files on your file system and
could make the sandbox like
non-functional basically. And so we need
to kind of protect the root FS running
on inside the sandbox. So we have a have
a shared base layer u of a rot fs that's
shared between sandboxes and you can see
that this is the yellow one with user
bin a here but on top of that every
sandbox gets its own like readrite
layer. So this is where all the new
files it creates uh go uh and so you
have this very nice uh balance between
the root fs being protected and shared
between sandboxes. uh but uh they get
their own like read write layer u and
when we snapshot a sandbox we also
persist or back up just the read write
layer we don't need to persist the reado
layer so we have this like nice sharing
and like per sandbox uh semantics
here okay and now let's go to the code
and actually see how this happens right
so u the sandbox when it boots up
already has this setup all it sees is
like a root mount path and just like any
other like Linux system. There's no
difference. But we do all the magic
before the sandbox uh as soon as the
sandbox boots uh and we start like the
first uh pit one inside the sandbox. Uh
and so you can see here we like uh uh
this is the init. script running inside
uh the guest which is our sandbox and
it's setting up this uh like overlay FS
here. Uh and as soon as it does that we
start like the booting process and like
boot to pit one. Um and every process uh
within our sandbox just sees like a
regular like file system but we've done
the magic
underneath. Yeah. And with that like
let's see our updated architecture. So
we had the rest server we have these
like microVM sandboxes and now we see
like uh every disk device is uh mounted
on top of this overlay FS u and each
sandbox gets its own like readrite
layer.
Okay, with that let's move on to
networking. Okay, every sandbox needs to
have networking. It might need to do
other actions or call other tools or
APIs. Um, and so we need to provide each
sandbox with a network. Um, and so each
sandbox in Ara runs in a virtual machine
like we discussed with its own isolated
networking. The networking setup
consists of a tab device. So each it's
like a virtual networking interface on
Linux. Each sandbox gets a unique tap
network device. So when we spawn the uh
microb sandbox, we are creating this tab
device for it. Um and we have a Linux
bridge on the host uh which is the Linux
server where um all the tab D tab
devices are connected to the Linux
bridge on the host. And the last part is
uh we take care of port forwarding. So
rack is like forwards post ports from
your host into like the code server or
the VNC server. So you don't have to
worry about how to access uh these
things uh on on your
sandbox. Okay. Uh let's go over some
code to set up networking here. So this
is a function from Arais. It sets up the
bridge device and it also sets up the
firewall rules to uh forward data back
and forth uh from the host to the
sandbox and the sandbox to the host. Um
and so you can see that like here we
come in and we create a bridge uh and we
set it to up u and then we set these
like firewall or forwarding rules that
are quite gnarly to set up but we've
taken uh care of them uh for you and
these decide how data flows from uh from
the host to the sandbox and back.
uh another function here that takes care
of port forwarding and you can see we
use like Linux IP tables command to do
that and uh uh like we have a
destination port inside the guest and we
have this like uh dnat argument here
that does all the magic and uh we call
this using like go command run um uh
yeah okay with networking setup our
updated architecture looks like this uh
we have the rest server spawning these
microVM sandboxes. U and now we see that
we've taken care of port forwarding. So
a VNC client running on your MacBook or
your laptop can easily access the GUI
via the VNC server uh running inside the
sandbox. Um as mentioned before uh we
use Docker tooling to customize Arais
sandboxes. So you can run whatever
packages and binaries you want uh by
just modifying a Docker file inside
Arais. Uh so let's take over the let's
take a look over the docker file that we
have by default. Uh and so you can see
we base it on
Ubuntu22.04 have these like standard
packages inside for your agents to be
productive without installing uh
anything else at runtime. Um and you can
see we also give you chrome uh installed
and we boot it via systemd inside the
sandbox. uh and also install like NodeJS
and npm so that you can make like node
apps. Python's also already installed.
So you can the agents can do a lot uh
with these tools inside the sandbox and
you can configure them for uh in the
future with whatever binaries you want
inside. Okay, let's put it all together
and see how we create a VM in code. Um
so as you can see like we create all the
devices we talked about. So there's a
root f there's the overlay fs writable
path. Here we allocate uh some vcpus
which are nothing but threads on your
host OS. We calculate some memory and
give it uh give it as a fraction of the
host memory available. Uh there's a
networking device so we created the tap
device uh as well and uh above in the
snippet we also did the port forwarding.
Um voc is a way to communicate between
the guest and the host. uh again uh and
then yeah finally we spawned a VMM
process um and then call this create VM
API on it with this configuration to
start a guest
VM as mentioned before uh code exec is
one of the very important
functionalities of an AI sandbox uh
arachis comes in bundled with a code
execution server uh here I show you the
exact code uh that's running inside the
code execution server there's the files
API to upload and download files. We'll
see in the cloud demo how this API is
used liberally by claude to send data
back and forth. And there's of course a
command uh uh API which takes in a
command, executes it and returns either
an output or error uh in the form of
JSON. Um we're running in a guest VM. So
I'm much more confident about this code
not escaping out and we can be relaxed
with it versus if we were running
directly on top of our host OS then I'd
be very very scared exposing something
like this. Uh on top of the code
execution server we also have Chrome
pre-installed and like I said uh we have
we do port forwarding for you to the to
your VNC server inside the sandbox. So
you can actually access Chrome directly
and the GUI directly inside your sandbox
very easily with
Arachus. Okay. Now let's talk about one
of the most exciting features of Arachus
snapshotting. Uh so what's the
motivation behind saving state of a
sandbox and snapshotting? So in general
um agents fail when you're giving them a
very big task like make me a Google News
like app. um because uh in inevitably
they fail somewhere during this big wake
task. So they need like a step-by-step
plan and as specific and as small the
plan the better the reliability. But
even then multi-stage plans can fail. So
imagine if you have a deep like almost
like a dag of execution. You do all the
work and you fail towards the very end.
Um you shouldn't have to start from
scratch. you should be able to backtrack
to the last good checkpoint, replan and
try again. So that's the motivation
behind snapshotting giving agents the
capability to fail and backtrack uh and
then at scale getting more reliable
results by exploring multiple paths uh
in parallel. Um so Arais lets agents
save the entire running state of a
sandbox. So this includes like just the
guest memory and the file system which
is the RW part of the overlays. So any
files it created, any processes it
spawned all will be u restored as is. So
imagine on your MacBook if you close the
lid and you open it up, it's exactly the
same semantic. Um and so yeah, any
processes found even like windows opened
in the GUI there that's nothing but uh
uh guest memory state. So they'll be
restored as is. Um and so agents can
backtrack to a good snapshot if they
fail and then replan and continue the
workflow. So this diagram shows like how
we can do this at scale. Um uh if we
fail we can just like back to um our
path of execution to a last known good
hash and like replan and try again.
Currently we don't use butterfs but our
plan is to use a um a file system that
natively aware is aware of uh
incremental snapshots and optimized for
such um and so we are exploring using
butterfs instead of ext4 for the file
system as
well. Uh now let's go over like how we
actually do the snapshotting in code and
there are like four steps. Um we
actually first pause the VM by calling
the pause API on the VMM. Um uh then we
call the snapshot API and um dump the
guest uh memory. Uh and then out of band
we manually like persist the thin uh
readwrite overlay FS to persist all the
files uh that the sandbox or the agent
uh created inside the sandbox. And
finally we resumed the VMM. So we
checkpointed it and then we just ran
sandbox again. So it keeps doing what it
has doing before. Uh and you can see
this in code, right? Um uh we go ahead
and pause the VM here. Um we make sure
we resume before we exit the function
here. Um we create a copy of the
stateful disk which is the readwrite
layer of the overlay FS. Uh yeah and
finally call snapshot which dumps the
guest memory uh for the VM and creates
this magical experience when you resume
it.
Okay, we've gone through the entire
architecture of Arachus and how you
would build AI sandbox like Arachus. Uh
let's put it all together and how would
we actually use it. So u Arachis comes
with a first class support for a Python
SDK. So you pip install the Pakis
package and it's very simple from then
on. You uh you self host Arais on your
own infrastructure, give it the IP here
to the sandbox manager. Um, you figure
out what all VMs are running by calling
the list all API that gives you metadata
about the VM, its IP, its ports. Um, you
start a sandbox with the start sandbox
API, run a command and see the output or
the error using the output or error JSON
keys. Um, and here's how you can
actually snapshot with just one command.
Like you give a snapshot ID. Um, and
then you destroy the VM if uh if when
you're done. Um, and later on when you
want to actually restore the checkpoint
from your snapshot, it's very simple.
You just call restore with your VM name
and you give the snapshot ID that you
got here from the snapshot call. So all
in all, a very dead simple API to use uh
spawn and use AI sandboxes for codeex
and other
things. Okay, so we've seen the
architecture of Ara. Uh now let's see uh
it in action. Um let's see claw desktop
make a Google Docs clone using Arais via
its MCP server. Um and you'll see that
we don't have to do a whole lot of
prompting or create a whole coding age
tool or framework. Uh it really does a
lot of heavy lifting if it once it
realizes it has access to a full-blown
like Linux sandbox. Uh so yeah, let's go
over the demo real
quick. Uh so you can see I prompted to
create a Google Docs clone. uh and that
has collaboration built in so multiple
people can join. Um we'll see that on
the right hand side we are running
arachis um and uh off the black claude
is just piping commands uh creates a
sandbox and pipes commands directly in
it creates this Google docs clone and we
have networking setup so people can type
in together. We can snapshot this
version as well. So we created a
snapshot of that copy and now we try to
add a feature on top of that uh clone.
Uh and so yeah we try to add dark mode
inside the Google Docs
clone. Let's see do this as
well. Okay let's see. So it added that
dark mode feature inside and you can see
it works. Collaboration hasn't broken.
Uh but I changed my mind. And I want to
go back to the snapshot we had before
without the dark mode. And so you can
see we can restore the old checkpoint
and go back to without dark mode
here. Right? So the cool part here is
that um uh it did the snapshotting and
and you could see it created end to end
apps without me prompting it again and
again. But since we took care of
networking, we could actually get a
completely collaborative experience like
full-on Google Docs thing uh versus just
like fake collaboration that other
client side uh uh codegen uh tools might
do. Um so that was like a one cool side
effect uh of the demo. Uh
yeah. Okay, let's discuss uh some of the
ongoing work in Arachus. Um top of mind
is definitely getting boot time to be
under 1 second uh and even lower if
possible. I know other sandboxes are
also going uh on this metric. Um second
is really really have first class
support for snapshots and persistence.
So what that means is moving to butterfs
um which is uh tailor made for
incremental snapshots. Um and then we
want to binack as many sandboxes on one
server as possible. So we need to do
dynamic memory management and resource
management. So ballooning or hot
plugging of uh uh or removal of memory
at runtime is very very important.
Um yeah that's it for today. I hope you
liked uh the presentation and you got an
why sandboxes are important, how they
are made uh from scratch and a taste of
like cutting edge Linux systems work.
Um, if any of this is interesting,
please get in touch with me uh at those
links. Uh, and I've uh left the links
for the launch video, the GitHub repo.
Yeah, happy to help anyone. Thanks so
much. Bye.